here he comes in oh god we've got
another volunteer here so you are on
channel one and it's that's it a little
bit farther away so you can bring that
down to a see get going we're hole de
either one yeah bring it down to a see
okay all right I'm on the G somebody's
on the June
Oh battery
here we go Oh beautiful LaVon hunter and
I'm a middle school teacher in the South
Bronx I'm Jane stuck a technology
teacher at the Marriott School of New
York my name is Sebastian Travis I'm the
co-founder of emptiness my name is
melissa lee and i managed the harlan DNA
lab email and Jorgenson i'm a molecular
biologist I named Stephanie I'm a
graduate student at Rockefeller
University I'm de San Davis I'm a
science teacher at hunter college high
school my name is Beth waters I'm the
lead scientist here in the science
outreach lab at market failure i'm janie
garbarino I'm the director of science
outreach here at the Rockefeller
University and the goal of today's have
on is to basically bring together people
who have an interest in changing the
face of life science education and make
it more creative and so
we want scientists to talk with
educators to talk with technologists to
top lid fabricators or designers or
artists and we think that everybody has
something to add to the conversation and
we want everybody to have an equal
platform and so we're trying to make a
day
that will give people the opportunity to
interact and the opportunity to share
their ideas with the hopes that maybe a
spark a spark will ignite some some
great project or a maybe some small
project that could make a larger small
difference in the classroom setting
my grandmother was one of the strongest
influences when I was about nine or ten
she told me a book about Darwin's voyage
around the world on the Beagle when he
was in his early 20s had started to
incubate the theory of evolution and I
got really excited about evolution about
how genetic changes that have shaped
life on Earth and and how everything's
encoded by DNA you can see when he's
relaxed or one he's excited about what
he's thinking about
and now i'm happy cuz on camera now
every day we're making more and more
discoveries and it's the world is so
dynamic and science is the tool that you
can use to uncover that dynamis ism
I knew that I had to give my students a
lab experience and knowledge expertise
right so that's what I struggle do every
day to make it real for them would be
able to see really with the data what a
circadian rhythm is so I had a little
baby sister who was uh you know
consuming a lot of diapers so I
basically did a diaper experiment try to
figure out what diapers absorb the most
water and we ought to present all our
projects in seventh grade and I was
asked to be part of a Bronx borough
science fair which I thought was I just
didn't expect it because teachers saw
something in me that maybe I didn't see
myself I just basic this one brown
psycho you look at anything you know
that nobody else in the world knows what
you know for a given moment you know
you're holding this data in your hand
and and you've discovered something that
that no one else knows and you're the
first and that's very addictive even
though most of the time when you try to
do something fails it's that reward that
keeps you going you are the teachers
that are making a dick
and I wish I had a teacher like you when
I was a kid the right one and A two and
three